don't give me another cloud for sake  because I think about event before I hit  the power friends you're a garbage  person boogies pump it work it work it  Justin nice now what'd you break if  you're ready to fight I'm all yours  why don't you come on then there's no  one else here we can be ourselves  finally you're so brash when will you  ever take elegant touch  [Music]  there's nothing standing in the way of  you taking charm  [Laughter]  [Music]  [Laughter]  [Laughter]  it seems that a young upstart like you  needs to be taught some manners I've  been educated in certain ways smelling  you when you come to Britain your tea  will be cold and your crumpets will be  burnt  [Music]  avast  shut up shut up I'm strong  [Laughter]  [Music]  [Music]  [Laughter]  my anxiety it's just a projection of my  anxiety on others  [Music]  [Laughter]  [Music]  [Music]  beep it's ok  [Music]  [Music]